and everyone and welcome to the security
of classic game consoles so I have the
pleasure of speaking after you all have
eaten lunch and you've got that that
food come como going on but then they
had the snack where we've loaded you up
with donuts and sugar so now you're all
hyped up and amped up and so let's ready
for a fun talk - and you're almost on
your strange loop conference my name is
Kevin Shackleton I am a distinguished
engineer at a company called Cerner
that's based in Kansas City Missouri we
do healthcare IT software and services
I've been there for 15 years and one of
my responsibilities is the security of
all of our software so I get to work
with all the teams at cerner to ensure
that where we have secure coding
principles that were that were including
security as a first-class design concern
of our software as you can tell from the
title of my presentation the music that
I had going on before here the slides up
here I am a fan of classic gaming and so
with this talk today I want to marry my
passions with security and classic
gaming into one and so let's get started
so growing up I was completely enamored
with the Nintendo Nintendo was my life
in fourth grade for my birthday after
begging my parents for several years
they finally got me this Nintendo right
here and I played this Nintendo
incessantly I had a subscription in
Nintendo Power and I read each issue
cover to cover repeatedly I got is my
hands on as many games as possible
I almost got a Nintendo Power glove but
my sister who was three years younger I
tried to convince her to pool our
allowance money together to purchase the
power glove and that worked for a couple
weeks until she realized that it was
just for me and she quickly wised up so
alas I did not get that but Nintendo
actually came about at an interesting
time so actually before Nintendo was
companies like Atari with Atari 2600 and
arcades those were very prevalent but
something happened in 1983 that we now
refer to as the video game crash of 1983
or Atari shocked
which the video game market completely
collapsed overnight going from a three
billion dollar market to a hundred
million dollars now there are a few
factors that we attribute to the crash
one of them being competition from home
computers so video game systems consoles
could only play video games but home
computers could play video games and do
exciting things like do spreadsheets and
word processors so video games were seen
as a fad but also you had a glut of
consoles that were out at the time and
more importantly a glut of console games
so the Atari 2600 the most popular
system of that time had hundreds upon
hundreds of games produced for it one of
them being the lovely et game which you
can see in a landfill here most of the
games were were completely terrible and
parents and kids don't didn't know which
which games were good and so for two
years this crash happened so from 83 to
85 the market was pretty much dead
people thought video games were a fad
until the fall of 1985 when in the u.s.
Nintendo released the Nintendo
Entertainment System now note they
called it the Nintendo Entertainment
System not the Nintendo video game
system of the Nintendo video console
because video games were a bad word and
the Nintendo could do more than video
games you could play with your Robby the
Robot there that you know obviously no
one ever did because everyone just
played games so it was it was really a
gaming console but you know with the
Nintendo they were coming out in this
time where video games were a bad word
it was pretty much a dead market and
they did not want to repeat the same
mistakes that happened in the past so
they did something that no one else had
really tried before which was for every
Nintendo game sold it had this seal from
Nintendo that said this seal is your
assurance the Nintendo has approved and
guaranteed the quality of this product
now for those who are familiar with this
game here Friday the 13th you'll know
that this is infamous for being one of
the worst video games of all time so
it's certainly not deserving of this the
seal of approval from Nintendo here so
that's not what the seal approval was
all about it was not about quality
actually with a seal meant was that as a
developer your game
to be on the Nintendo for two years and
only on the Nintendo no other system so
you were locked in so the Friday the
13th developers know Nintendo was the
lucky system that got that game for two
years as a developer you can only
produce five games a year so Nintendo
immediately constrained the market so
developers couldn't pump out games left
and right you had just five games that
you could release in a year before Apple
made content review the fet you know the
latest cool thing with iOS Nintendo was
doing it back on the NES and so they
went all games went through a content
review with Nintendo and then finally
and this is the crucial bit here
Nintendo controlled all the
manufacturing of the games so every game
cartridge sold was produced by Nintendo
and that's how they ensured they got a
cut of every game sold so as a developer
you'd go to nintendon't say I'm going to
produce a million copies of my game and
Nintendo might say well we're only gonna
let you do 500,000 and you'll say okay
that's fine and the Nintendo would say
and we want all the money up front to
produce those games even if we're gonna
spread it out over say a couple year
period
you'd have to upfront all that money and
then any unsold inventory that you had
you just had to eat that so these terms
seem incredibly lopsided right they
favor Nintendo so why would any
developer agree to them well the
developers were forced to because
Nintendo made security a first-class
design consideration when building the
nest unlike other systems and we're
gonna talk a little about a little bit
about that in a second so first let's
transition away from the terrible Friday
the 13th and let's talk about the
awesome Mega Man 2 so for those who who
are in here earlier yeah you can clap
for Mega Man 2 it's fine yeah so the
music I had playing was from Mega Man 2
and this is one of my favorite games of
all time I I got this game as a kid
played it constantly this was one of the
first games that I beat so as a kid like
I got a lot of satisfaction that I was
able to beat this game and it's just
it's regarded as a fantastic video game
so like I said I brought with me today
my my Nintendo I've modified it a bit
I've also brought with me a copy of Mega
Man 2 and what I'd like to do if you to
indulge me a bit is I'd like to continue
my presentation from my modified Mega
Man 2 and I'm going to talk about
security of not only the Nintendo but
other videogame systems and how can we
learn from those principles and the
software and systems we build today
so let's if we could switch to the VGA
inputs there
thank you and we have to blow on it you
know of course all right so we've got
Megaman 2 I've made a little bit of
modifications for strange loop here
let's actually make one more
modification ah much better ok alright
so let's start here now thankfully the
designers of Megaman 2 designed the game
so that there was an the exact number of
bosses as the systems and things I
wanted to talk about so certainly I
didn't shoehorn anything in here we
already talked about the crash and kind
of a precursor to our talk today so
let's get into our first system and
let's look at the Intellivision 2 so
this system actually predated Nintendo
this was before the video game crash and
the Intellivision 2 was created by a
company called Mattel so we all know
Mattel and Mattel actually created the
Intellivision first and they made their
own games for the Intellivision but so
did other companies one of those
companies was calico so Kalika would
produce games for the Intellivision
but in television didn't see a dime from
from those games and then Cliquot vision
released a system called the
ColecoVision now I don't know about you
guys but something looks very familiar
about these two systems ColecoVision you
know shamelessly stole the amazing
controller and keypad design for their
ColecoVision all joking aside the
ColecoVision is actually my second
favorite system I grew up playing that
before the Nintendo it's a fantastic
gaming console but you know in Mattel
was not happy that Kalika was competing
both in the gaming market and now the
hardware market so when they released
the Intellivision 2 when you turn it on
and put in a game and
we jump back here before the code is you
got you you got this green screen that
says Mattel electronics presents the
name of the game which came from the ROM
is a game and then a copyright and then
the the copyright year and company also
from the ROM and when you took the
Intellivision - is a backwards
compatible system so when you took in
television games and plug them in until
into the television - everything worked
when you took those Coleco games though
they were made for the Intellivision
they did not work on the Intellivision -
and why is that
well when the Intellivision - booted up
the exact processor executive rom that
that was built into the system had this
check in there which basically it said
is bit 6 of address 500 see set if not
then halt and don't load the game and if
that bit was set then it checks the
copyright year in the header and it says
if it's between 1978 and 1982 then it
allows the game to play if not then it
halts well the Mattel branded games the
games made from Mattel all of these
checks passed and they were able to play
but those Coleco games that were made
for the Intellivision did not have these
value set and so they didn't the game
would not load so this is a very
rudimentary but it's I call this out
because it's the first attempt at
security with with consoles now this was
easily defeated by Cliquot but by that
time we had the crash of 83 and so it
was all moot so but it's just
interesting nonetheless now let's talk
about Nintendo so let's move on back to
our Nintendo and and by the way if you
don't appreciate these transitions it's
through every single one so you'll have
to you have to get used to it I went all
in here so if we open up our Nintendo I
mentioned that security was Nintendo
consider that a design concern of that
then yes so if I were to take the cover
off my Nintendo here the cartridge
slides in from the bottom so we're
looking at a top-down view and if we
look at this particular chip here and
I'm gonna zoom into this chip this chip
is called the nest checking integrated
circuit but we just call it a 10 nest
chip so the 10 nest chip is in every
single Nintendo console and if I were to
open up my Megaman 2 cartridge inside of
that cartridge is that circuit board and
the exact
ten nest chip is in the cartridge okay
so it's the exact same chip now in the
console the chip acts as a lock and in
the cartridge that it acts as a key now
we know Nintendo produces all the
consoles and if you remember Nintendo
produces and manufactures every
cartridge so that's how they're able to
put this chip into every cartridge now
when your Nintendo console boots up the
ten nest chip here on the console
generates a seed so a random number that
it then sends to the ten nest chip or
the key in the cartridge so now both the
two tennis chips have the same seed
they're both the same chips they do the
same arithmetic calculations the chip in
the cartridge sends the results back to
the console the lock and the lock
compares the results if the result
matches then all is good and it then
does this all over again if the results
don't match for any reason and there's
some sort of communication problem the
chip in the console sends the reset
command to the CPU so you know how when
I blew on the cartridge because I was
getting the flashing red light not
getting in the game to come on and when
that happened to as a kid what that
really was
was that your game was not getting a
good connection to the console and it's
specifically to the 10s chip and it was
setting a reset command so your game
comes up it flashes resets and keeps
doing that over and over again so when
you think we're blowing the dust out of
the the cartridge of the console we're
really not it's really the insertion
into the cartridge that just repeatedly
just gets at a better connection now
thankfully Nintendo patented the ten
nest chip and so we have schematics for
it and we have a description for how it
works and one of the interesting things
is that buried into the into this patent
is the description as how does the chip
know that it's a lock when it's in the
console versus if it's in the cartridge
is the key and that's because and the
way they do that is the console has
power right this is plugged in it's
drawing power and in that mode it's the
chip is getting positive five volts of
power which means that it's going to
operate in lock mode the cartridge
doesn't have any power so it's operates
in key mode but there's this air
scenario that's called out that's very
interesting that says in the
situation in which you have a key key
combination or lock lock combination so
you don't have the combination of lock
and key then the chip does nothing it
doesn't reset the CPU so it's
effectively if there's no security in
place and that's actually our first
attack factor so if we go and snip pin 4
on the lower left-hand corner of the
chip here we disconnect its power that
positive 5 volts and now this chip acts
as a key so we're now in a key key
configuration it doesn't reset the CPU
all is good so you can go in modern
Nintendo and just snip that snip that
pin and everything works fine now in
security this principle is called that
you know in this design they're failing
open so in a fail open design in the
case of an error there's like no
security so for instance if we're in a
room and there's normally locked doors
that don't let access to the outside
like say maybe this door but there's
like a fire or some emergency you'd want
it to fail open so we don't get trapped
in the room and we can get out so that's
a case where fail open is fine but in
this case we probably don't want to fail
open because we can easily dismantle the
security here a fail closed design would
be where in this error scenario it would
still continue to reset the CPU so it
you know it it doesn't allow things to
proceed now there's another attack
vector here which is we can knock this
tennis chip offline so Nintendo produced
all the cartridges and all their
cartridges don't have any power to them
right
well what if we produced a malicious
card cartridge that sent negative 5
volts back to our console which would
negate the positive 5 volts that our
tendinous chip gets and so now it knocks
it off line turns it effectively into a
key and we could disable security that
way and actually there was developers
who produced cartridges that did just
that Nintendo didn't anticipate that or
in the security world we talked about
they weren't checking their inputs right
so Nintendo actually fixed this in later
revisions to the nest where they added
some diodes in to protect against
unwanted voltages to protect against
this attack but it's an interesting
thing to consider that you know Nintendo
thought they were the only ones that you
know could possibly produce cartridges
but really a malicious attacker could do
so as well
and then the final attack vector with
the Ness is that you know we have this
this key in here the dis lock and this
key effectively they're sharing a
symmetric secret between each other we
have access to those so we can
reverse-engineer that and simply clone
our own key and that's actually what a
developer called 10gen did so here is
gauntlet from 10gen you can tell this
doesn't look like a normal Nintendo
cartridge it's black it has a slightly
different shape but this cartridge has a
clone of the 10s chip that they called
the rabbit chip in here now what's
interesting is Tenjin is actually a
subsidy of a company called Atari so
Atari made nintendo games under 10gen
and they didn't want to pay nintendo
licensing fees so they reverse
engineered the 10s chip put it in their
cartridges and the game would play now
Nintendo actually sued ten Atari and
actually Nintendo won their suits the
court ruled that if you know 10 done
just simply reverse engineered the 10s
chip everything would have been fine
however they didn't do it in a cleanroom
environment so as it turns out an
employee of 10 Jen went to the US
Copyright Office for Nintendo had stored
a copy of the code for the 10s chip and
they obtained that code so they could
aid in their reverse engineering of the
chip so Nintendo did prevail there so
the lesson learned here is you know
these effectively are symmetric secrets
we have access to them so someone could
reverse-engineer them so symmetric
secrets are only good if the attacker
has no way to access that secret now
let's move on to our next system the
Sega Genesis
so the Sega Genesis one of the first
16-bit systems they also had a seal
their own sealed a Sega seal of quality
and when you turn on your Genesis and
put in a Genesis game you were greeted
with this screen produced by or under
license from Sega enterprises and this
actually was documented in Sega's
developer kit so this was not a secret
as to what they were doing here so the
say the Sega trademark security system
or TMS at TMS s checks to see if the
word Sega is in memory address 100 and
if so it goes ahead and loads the game
now this was the this was documented in
their in their developer SDK so they
weren't trying to hide this like in like
in television or Mattel was so instead
Sega's security measure was interesting
and that they were going for both a
trademark and a licensing kind of legal
maneuver here where if you as a
developer had the word Sega in your code
but you were not a licensed developer
Sega would go after you and say hey
that's a that's a trademark infringement
and when the black screen came up that
said this game was produced or licensed
by Sega well that'd be a lie because it
actually wasn't so they went after you
for that and so they actually sued a
developer for this accolade in 92 Sega
initially won but then they ended up
losing on appeal and the appeals court
ruled that accolade
was it within their means to go ahead
and reverse engineer the Genesis because
they had it in their possession and they
could do whatever they wanted with it
I mean this was actually a very
influential case that has cited in other
reverse engineering cases throughout
history
so next let's talk about another sega
system the Sega Saturn
so the Sega Saturn was notable for being
one of the first systems that employed
CD media for their for their gaming so
we moved away from cartridges and moved
to CDs and the Saturn game CDs were
actually just like regular CDs with one
small exception so the Saturn Sega CDs
had this ring this outer ring that
normal cd-rom readers cannot write or
read and in this outer ring was a
signature that we called a static wobble
signature and this signature was
basically a private key that Sega would
encode into each one of the game so Sega
for the Saturn produced all of the games
which allowed them to get those
licensing fees now before I talk about
how this was broken I'd like to shift
and talk about a paper from 1975 called
the protection of information in
computer systems by Salter and Schroeder
this is a fantastic research paper I
know research papers can sometimes be
difficult to read but this one is very
easy to read and it's so relevant still
today this paper goes through various
security principles when building
computer systems and all of them are
still applied today and so for all the
rest of the the measures I'm going to
talk about today I want to kind of
relate those back to this paper because
it's really interesting so one of the
security principles they talk about in
this paper is a concept called work
factor and work factor is something that
we're very familiar with today with
cryptography and passwords and work
factor basically says for an attacker
you can compute in some cases you can
compute the amount of work it would take
to compromise the system and some cases
though the work factor is not easily
calculated but in the case of like
cryptography with passwords you can say
okay we know here's how many possible
password combinations there are here's
how many hashes I can compute say per
second and so you know the work factor
it would take you to a crack to a given
password so with word factor you want
the amount of work that an attacker has
to expend to be less than the value of
the thing you're trying to attack
okay so in other words an attacker is
not going to want to spend time and
energy and effort and the payoff is you
know not worth it in the end because it
took them too long so the Sega Saturn CD
security it's a extremely high work fat
work factor because in order to break it
we have to create our own CD writer
capable of writing on a regular CD disk
that security signature - you know
counterfeit a Saturn game and in fact no
one has actually done this so no one has
produced a Saturn CD burner to burn you
know Saturn games it just it hasn't been
broken so does that mean the Saturn has
you know this security measure has never
been broken not quite so in that paper
when they talk about work factor they
talk about that if the work factor is
too high that defeat of the security
measure is often obtained through
indirect means and that's exactly what
happened with the Saturn so instead of
attacking the CD the format of the CD in
that static wobble signature instead
attackers went after it with a disc swap
attack which we put in a legitimate disc
it reads that the console reads the
security signature on that little bit
the legitimate disc and then you yank
that out and put in your burn disk and
we'll read the game data from that so
it's effectively a timing based attack
another way that the Saturn's been
hacked is simply through modding it
right we have the console in our
possession we can modify the circuits
and and one notable console hacker
actually about a year year and a half
ago modded his Saturn to load games off
of a USB stick so there's lots of
different ways to attack systems so you
know work factor is came into play here
the next system I want to talk about is
the Sony Playstation so the Sony
Playstation is a system I'm sure
everyone is familiar with it was very
popular in the 90s it also used a disk
based system like the Saturn and like
the Saturn it was a regular cd-rom with
a special you know secret signature or
key that was written on the outer edges
but the PlayStation was attacked even
easier than the Saturn and that's due to
a design
law so the way the PlayStation would
work normally is when you put in a CD it
would read the cd-rom signature that
wobble region data and then they
actually use it for more region control
so that you couldn't play say a Japanese
game in the US or US game in Japan as
long as that checked out that signature
checked out which is it turns out was
just four characters on the edge of the
disk it would then read some license
screen text from the the disc and kind
of display that on the screen so this is
we're kind of marrying a the the static
signature from the Saturn plus the the
Genesis kind of like copyright security
that kind of legal maneuvering there but
I want to call your attention to the
back of the PlayStation here so in the
back of the playstation in the lower
left-hand corner is a parallel port and
this with this parallel port it had
access to pretty much the whole system
so attackers were able to create a
device that plugged into the parallel
port that when the laser on the seat on
the the console was was reading the
signature on the disk and if you had a
burn disk that didn't have that it
wouldn't find it
well the device in the parallel port
would inject into the data stream the
expected characters so it was able to
hijack that data stream and put in those
characters and so the game that the OS
thought that it was reading the data
from the disk when in fact it's coming
from the parallel port and then that
license screen text that it needed to
read from the game to display the the
copyright screen or the licensing screen
when you started up the PlayStation it
would tell the console the parallel port
the device from the parallel port would
tell the console I'm we need to switch
discs and in the multi disc game the
second disc did not have that license
text and so the the game console would
just ignore it and not display that so
they kind of avoided all that now if we
go back to our 1975 paper there's a
concept they talked about called
principle of least privilege and that's
the entities and and actors in your
system should have only the necessary
privileges to operate and nothing more
and so if we talk about our PlayStation
here and look at it the parallel port
probably has no business to be able to
inject data into the data stream coming
off of the laser or to tell the system
that it should
disks that should come from the game
itself and when we talk can we think
about the systems we build today like
when we're running our applications on a
server we don't want them to run his
route right because that has way too
many privileges instead we'd want to run
it as a less privileged user so Sony
actually wised up to this and so this is
the how the PlayStation looked in 1994
and five years later in 1999 they
removed the parallel ports so rather
than reducing the privileges on the
parallel port they just removed it all
together which as it turns out is
another security principle from our
favorite paper from 1975 and they call
that economy of mechanism now this is
kind of an awkward term I think but
today we use this term all the time but
just in a different form with kiss or
keep it simple stupid
and what economy of mechanism describes
is that the more simple your system is
the less moving parts you know the
smaller you can make it the easier it is
to reason about your system the easier
it is to understand all the code paths
the easier it is to test it and given
two systems one more complex than the
other the simpler system will be far
easier to secure and should have less
security bugs and that's exactly what
Sony did here just by removing the
parallel port they just removed it in
you know a whole attack vector here and
simplified the design of the PlayStation
and as it turns out that parallel port
was actually never even used for
anything other than people hacking their
consoles so now let's go back to Sega
and let's talk about the Sega Dreamcast
so Sega Dreamcast's was a great system
unfortunately it didn't do so great in
the market and also unfortunately it was
it was crippled with a severe security
vulnerability now recall that Sega when
they had with the Saturn they had that
proprietary format with that static
signature on around the outer edge and
the Dreamcast employed something similar
so the Dreamcast could read audio CDs
and all of the games came in this format
that was brand-new from Sega a
proprietary format called gd-rom so
normal CDs could hold up to you know six
fifty or seven hundred Meg's GT roms
were gigabyte discs and Sega of course
produced all the they pressed all the GD
roms so again like the Saturn with this
proprietary format they're the only ones
capable of writing these discs they're
Owens capable of reading it in terms of
the dreamcast reader so you think that
and also you know we can't just do what
like what we did with the Saturn and
burn a a regular CD because these are
gigabit or gigabyte games not games that
fit on just a regular CD so we've got
some challenges here but there's a third
format that this the Dreamcast was able
to read and that's another proprietary
format from Sega called mill CD and I'm
sure most of you have not heard this
format Sega introduced it thinking that
they were going to create this great new
audio CD with like a hybrid of a data CD
and this would be like this interactive
audio CD so it's really an audio CD plus
executable code and when we add
executable code to things that never
works out well so these are the three
formats the Dreamcast could support and
so attackers they knew okay we're not
going to go and try to you know create
our own gd-rom writers or readers or
media so what if we could take a gd-rom
disk and put that on a mil CD because
that has executable code and that's
exactly what they did so using the
dreamcast itself they put in a
legitimate game they would stream the
data off of the dreamcast on and send
that to a computer so they could dump
the games then most games actually fit
on a normal 700 mega CD but for those
that didn't they would just down sample
art or music to get it to fit onto a
regular cd-rom and they burned that
cd-rom in the mill CD format which while
it was proprietary from Sega the they
published how you could produce your own
mill CD formatted discs and so there was
no audio on the mill CD there was just a
bunch of data that happened to be the
game from the GT ROM and so the
Dreamcast would play that just like a
normal game here and so the lesson
learned here is that a
haxe follow the path of least resistance
so attackers are not going to go the
hard route of trying to reverse-engineer
how to press and make their own GD roms
they're just going to see how can they
exploit these other formats that exist
or other attack vectors that exist on
the Dreamcast so we've talked about some
classic gaming consoles and now I'm
going to look a bit at some systems
today so I know this talk is focused on
classic gaming consoles but we can learn
even more if we take a look at the
console systems that are coming out
today
so today with modern consoles the work
factor is just too high meaning that no
one is modding consoles anymore you're
not taking your your we're your switch
or your Gamecube and trying to mod it
it's too risky
the systems are really complex the the
componentry is getting more and more
integrated so it's harder to reverse
engineer this for you know a single
person to do that and you know the media
is is all digital right so we've moved
away from from physical media so some of
these other systems you know like the
the Gamecube had had these really small
disks that you couldn't burn so you
couldn't even take a regular CD so it's
just really difficult so attackers moved
away from the hardware and the the
physical media and instead went to
something that we're all familiar with
which is the software so now all the
attacks were happening all in the
software so with the Gamecube that was
routed through this game or one of the
ways were if there's scheme called
Phantasy Star Online Phantasy Star
Online was an online game and you could
you connected to the the server from a
Sega the manufacturer of the game and in
the game you could put into network
settings to connect to their server one
of those being a DNS server so attackers
figured out that if they put in a DNS
server that they controlled they could
use DNS hijacking to win the game
requested say Phantasy Star Online comm
the DNS server that the attacker
controlled actually told it hey that
servers available at this IP address
which is another server that the
attacker controls and so the game then
connects to that server so now the game
is thinking that it's connecting to
legitimate server but it's really
connecting to the attackers malicious
server that malicious server then told
the game hey Phantasy Star Online I have
an update for you you need to take this
patch and run this code and the game
said ok and it took that malicious code
ran it and then the the Gamecube was was
routed in that way and then you could
start playing other unlicensed games on
the Gamecube with the Nintendo Wii
anyone play Zelda The Twilight Princess
fantastic
lots of people fantastic game that
with the Wii there was a buffer overflow
in the games handling of savegame files
so when you saved your game in in Zelda
you could take that save game file and
put it on an SD card so you could take
it to a friend's house and play it on
their system
what attackers rebels figure out is if
you open up that save game file and
modify the attribute for the name of
Link's horse that was that would that
the character could modify and you made
that a malicious value when the game
read that in on on loading the save game
file it would execute a buffer overflow
attack and you could route the the we so
you can the the developers here kind of
like on the original Nintendo were they
the designers a Nintendo weren't
thinking that someone making malicious
cartridge to send negative five volts of
power to the Nintendo
Nintendo with the Zelda developers they
thought well we're the only ones writing
the save game file all of the inputs are
constrained by the the the characters on
the screen that were you know forcing
the player into they didn't think that
someone would would hack that so you
always need to check your inputs here
and then finally in the Nintendo switch
so the Nintendo switch came out earlier
this year I picked mine up it's it's
great but like all you know new systems
it comes with a web browser and the
switch comes with a version of WebKit
and the version that they shipped with
happen to be six months old and there
was known C V's and WebKit with that
version and so untrusted code was
running on the switch pretty quickly
after its release now to Nintendo's
credit I'm sure that the version of
WebKit that they shipped with or that
they they cut their kind of gold master
with was probably the most recent but
due to manufacturing time and
distribution delays you know it's gonna
get old and CV and vulnerabilities gonna
be discovered so it's really a very
difficult problem to solve here and just
shows that you know with all of these
newer systems it's much more easier to
attack the software than it is the
hardware in the media so for those who
have beaten Megaman 2 you'll recognize
that this is the ending screen so every
we've reached the end of our
presentation today
so what I want to leave you with is by
examining the tax of the various game
consoles throughout history we can learn
that
security principles that we can apply to
the software and the systems that we
build today thank you very much for your
time and thank you
[Applause]